[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys
[Music]
can you guys hear me fine am i coming
through
fine is there any issues with the sound
the title was all capped tidal is all
capped
but you got to prove it you have to
prove that it's all cat forte
can't just come in here making fix your
audio what's wrong with my audio
what is wrong with my audio
what's wrong with it
maybe there's just something wrong with
you forte maybe there's nothing wrong
with my audio it's just you
did you ever think about that maybe it's
just you
oh i'm too low i just think i just fixed
it i think i just fixed it
does that sound better am i coming
through clear
this is where i was
i said i gotta talk to this chick hold
up
brave soul pretty
lovely so do i sound fine now man do i
sound fine
do i sound fine
all right everyone says i sound fine man
what is it see the sound the power of
souls
look how built i am man of course
after all they'll require strength
go ahead touch the demon inside me
oh let's let these vagabond souls become
thine own
that's that's that's that's kind of
kinky
okay here we go
[Music]
11.
let's go with that for now
wha what is what is what is erica
over here talking about finished
let's see here
a strength build i i don't know this
game well enough to be making strength
builds and stuff man
i don't know the game well enough to be
doing that
gotta give me one second um
the filter a little bit
i guess i guess it doesn't matter
let's just go ahead and have it the way
it was i'll fix it later
all right
all right let's see here oh
strength build easier to make
are you guys saying i i'm not capable of
making a build that's not strength
is that what we're saying ow
they got like four of these things over
here trying to clap me
where's the next one
oh i feel like we got it for that
one ow
i hate these little blob things they're
annoying you gotta take them like slow
you gotta take them slow use fire you
don't need to use fire if you can get
behind them
i don't really wanna waste items
all right there we go i had to change
stuff a little bit i had to change stuff
a little bit
i wanted to see the chat a little bit
more clear i couldn't see it as clear as
i wanted to
yeah they trying to backseat game it
ain't going it ain't gonna matter
i i don't really baxi gaming don't
really upset me
how many is up here it's gonna be hard
to get behind them
whoa what is that
i ain't gonna see here and waste health
off one person
i'ma have to keep it moving
oh another damn dragon this game loves
throwing dragons at me
i don't think i'm gonna make it i think
he's gonna get me
oh my god how'd i make that
let's get this
[Applause]
oh he barely got maybe barely missed him
will he get me on the sides here is it
[Applause]
um
dragons are crazy man
i feel like he's gonna grab me at any
time
[Applause]
let's get these items
dragon scares the living hell out of me
man
scares me makes me think he gonna get me
he's gonna keep let's going
this
they love using these dragons to to
to get you uh brap asked me is this your
fault so
first souls game no
[Applause]
it is definitely not my first souls game
what's going on hardhead
[Applause]
oh god oh god
look at these people man
they thinking they being cute
how'd that go for you guys
they did hit me a couple times i'll give
them that they hit me a couple times
[Applause]
how long is this bridge it looks like
it's another
section
playstation just backtracking on closing
there
oh they did hold up they backtracked
send me the late
send me the link
see what else i'll be telling you guys
oh
don't say anything don't
you you're just gonna have to be quiet
no like these companies are scared of
their consumers man they're scared of
them
oh god what is that sound
and what the hell is that
oh it's the dude that that you buy stuff
from
ah we hope you find something that suits
you
plane
oh god dogs
wow i knew there was something down
there i was scared of
well that that that that kind of hit me
hard man
and the worst part about it it'd be long
like they like it'd be
crazy long
that's good that they did that man
that's good
all right what i have half my health
again
i'm not fighting them again those things
take too long
now half my health i got to go through
all this bulls snap
again
with half my health i assume to get my
health i gotta go get my souls
where's this stupid dragon
on the road again
a winged spear
all right so we gotta have an 85 inch
strength to use this beard
but it's cool man we're going to keep
using it we're gonna keep rolling
i can't can't expect him to keep
everything man
oh my god i got greedy
i got greedy i got two greedy i wanted
it all
and i still don't have my full health
ow
still don't have my full health man i'm
not liking that
[Music]
where is that dragon there he is why are
these
dragons terrorizing you man there's got
to be a reason on the way to the tower
so there's a tower night in this game i
should be scared of got you
tower night scared of it
should i put on the armor and fight the
terror night man
what the the tower night i assume that
this this night is at the end of this
section
i assume that's what's happening here
i'm not stopping for none of that stuff
i don't like how they trying to do me
though
completely failed that
how does this dude live
i call [ __ ]
oh i got this stupid oh my god
why do i keep switching to that
keep switching to that stupid dagger and
it keeps costing me help
run straight there
oh great
wow they really doing
some crazy stuff man
there's got to be a way to get my health
back
my health being half the half my health
is what's
killing me wow
why wouldn't you run i'm not fighting
these globs these globs are not worth my
time
and this dragon takes forever
oh running running running
i feel like going downstairs i'm not
trying to deal with those dogs again
though like on the rail
those dogs was a little intimidating
just a little bit
all right brett appreciate
i i might not make it i shouldn't have
waited so long
oh
oh my god
there we go it's a little bit better
[Applause]
the game looks good
i think people were exaggerating a
little bit saying it's the great it's
the
the best looking game ever made i do
think people are exaggerating on that
but it's definitely a nice looking game
there's no denying that
on the road again
this is ridiculous
geez like how do i get my health back
let me go to the stupid nexus maybe
that's how i get it back
or do i have to talk to oh homegirl gone
never mind she m.i.a
oh she's right there nevermind do you
restore my health
soul of the mind no you don't i shall
await thy return
slayer i am here give me my health back
you knew here the name and trade with
your souls
i definitely don't have a thousand
dollars oh you got a dollar to my name
i don't even got a dollar to my name
no i don't get my full health erica i
need that full health
i don't know how to get it though i had
it a minute ago
what happened they feel like i didn't
deserve my full health
oh my god
don't get your full health
i had but the thing is is i just had
full health
like you only die one time you lose all
your health what kind of nonsense that
i literally just had full health
i call this bull
oh my god let's grab this and
die because i grabbed hell health is
gonna get me killed
they played me they played me
oh my god that was scary i thought i was
done i thought it was over
so like i never get my health back is
that what you're telling me
i gotta play the rest this game with
half my health
[Applause]
is that what you saying
i don't like the way that's going man
i feel like that's that's nonsense
imma use a shield
people say to use the shield i'm going
to use the shield
i don't like the way you guys are
talking in this chat
so this has a huge
i look pretty human to me if i just say
so myself
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
why is this dude oh my god this is
getting on my nerves
oh my dude i just don't understand why i
have half my health
well i don't know i just started playing
this game i don't know the rules
i do have a clean line
okay okay that that that helps a little
bit
gives me a little bit of that health man
just a little bit
look how close this dragon gets man
[Applause]
you get full again by defeating a boss
or other ways
so that's the only way
that's crazy
that's crazy that's the only way
i didn't i don't know why i thought i
could break that
[Applause]
i had full health when i was fighting
those when those dogs killed
i had full health when those dogs killed
me
let's go
let's try this this this nonsense again
better use the shield actually i think
i'm going to use a
a dual hand that way i could kill these
archers faster
[Applause]
oh what is this dude doing man
[Music]
i don't like how they be doing that man
how'd that go for you
it's bad in demon souls oh i didn't know
that
it's fine though i i'm over it
what is that hold up wait a minute
that that looks pretty intimidating
oh it looks like it's just another one
of these nights these weird nights
that are very backstab friendly may i
add
the detail on the knight is pretty cool
though
oh no
i thought that are you serious how much
health is it
go ahead and keep eating stuff man
you're too predictable
yeah that didn't work out for you
what's going on come on i definitely
probably butchered your name i apologize
it was not intentional man
what's this way
what is that
i think i feel like i should have killed
him quicker
alright so you can't break that
let's go kill these knights up here
that's what they want me to go do
how'd that go for you guys you guys are
idiots you just sat up there waiting for
me to kill you
double hand sword
it was it was a help moment for them
they kind of do need the help
i don't know why anyone would is that
like can i get up there
i feel like that ladder's up there for a
reason oh it's broke that's just for
cosmetic purposes
stop being a hater george man
it's it's just a game man i
i can assure you me playing demon subs
does not
uh it doesn't get me to go and just
trade in my
xbox i got everything man it's it's fine
man i got everything
i even got a switch
i need to repair this sword i assume
that red down there is the sword
oh god oh god
oh god
oh there's archers too
my god
okay so i got to get up there and take
out the archers
and i can't get hit the moment the damn
game starts
the biggest thing i gotta do is
look man it's it's a process of
elimination
i knew the moment i saw those archers
because there was a time
and um and bloodborne where they had
archers
on top of these like little relic things
what's up mccain it's something trade
with your souls
do come back alive
all right let's try this again let's do
this again man i
i'm determined to beat him today but i
might not
i don't want to act like i'm going to
it's not a guarantee yeah i know
to to go double sword i know that
thanks for honest
oh oh
let's go up here
it's kind of okay the dragon's still
here i kind of figured the dragon was
gonna be still here
[Applause]
i wonder what's in that basement i
wonder if i should try to take on those
dogs again
are you gonna come on man i don't got
time for all this
do your damn job dragon
thank you
[Applause]
hold up
my apologies people people are very rude
wait for this dragon to come around so i
can get through this bridge
come on
these blue knights all sadly they
respawn
[Music]
oh my god at least he's kind of slow
what's up buddy
i'm over here
buddy
what's she doing
[Music]
buddy
and you're not getting your health back
because i know it's the first thing
you're gonna try to do
they always try to get the help
man look he he he booking it over here
buddy
oh
gotcha
cake all right here we go here we go
again
take two action
let me get that little bit of health
back because homeboy hits me one time
it's a rap
so so the goal is to get is to go around
this [ __ ]
go right let's let's do a sword
let's kill one
what is he doing
homeboy with the shield is doing some
nonsense
homeboy with the shield is doing some
nonsense
what is he doing
man you're big enough you don't need
these people's helps
you could take me on by yourself
oh it's a projectile
he's throwing he's throwing some spears
at me
he's a spear throwing fool
i feel like at that i feel like that's
fierce hit me man it's a wrath
all right so it looks like
oh enough with the spears
is this
all right all right here we go let's go
let's go
let's try to stay behind him
oh my god
what's up that's gloom for some reason
time to eat let's eat
i'm breaking something
[Music]
i'm breaking something
how is this going oh oh he
he he got me man he got
oh she's like a a mystical knight or
something
oh i got you that time ow
oh i don't want to get hit by that
shield
i don't want to get hit by the shield
gotcha all right all right all right
no shield being bashed something to do
with his legs
uh
i wish there was a shortcut
you don't have any more powers to use
look man
i could use the basta sword now
you're not strong enough to use it with
one hand
i'm not trying to use it okay so this is
a one-hand sword
because i'm not strong enough to use it
with one hand and that that's perfectly
fine
oh yeah that's right there's no there's
no loading there's no saving screen
ah we gotta do that again man we gotta
do that again
so let's go ahead and switch the metal
breaker to this long sword that i've
been using
so i can use this thing with two hands
when i need to
because you guys see me man i like using
the two-handed approach
i feel like that'll work out well in my
favor if i say so myself
because to be honest with you with this
big night i'm not even really using the
shield a lot
like when he hits me he just hits me
like there's nothing a whole lot i could
do about it
i just can't get hit by that shield like
i can get hit by some of the stuff
just that shield will obliterate me if
i'm around it
let's see how much damage this
two-handed does
here here's this ow
i don't feel like i don't feel the the
damage increase like i thought i would
[Applause]
got a little bit more strategic when you
use this thing
[Applause]
ow
so i'm pretty sure like what you have to
do is you have to keep hitting his
legs or something like that and then
something drastic is gonna happen when
you hit his legs
let's go down here let's go down here
last time i came down here
it was bad but let's go down here now
i hear the dogs you guys hear the dogs
maybe i don't hear the dogs i don't know
wow
i gotta go block more when uh
it's hard to see in this game sometimes
wow wow these dogs man
they fast i think i could kill them
though i think there is a good way of
killing these dogs if i wanted to
but for right now we're just going to
stick with the long sword
for right now
we're going to use that two-handed sword
when we actually get to the boss himself
because i feel like that that two-handed
that that that armor dude wasn't that
bad once i got rid of the archers
and to be honest with you he might not
have been that bad even with the archers
if i would have
keep using a shield but you guys know
i'll be doing that
that dumb stuff man all right i got i
gotta
be i gotta be loose and fast
for some reason i feel like the armor
dude would be will be a lot easier
without uh
being a little bit more agile too
it's it's a good thing playstation did
that man they they all
i probably just screwed up
ow
what's up man
on the road again
i try to oh he always goes back no
no don't don't go back come here
i hounded you in a second there's no
need to rush this
[Music]
look man i gotta deal with your buddy
first
you know what
i don't gotta deal with any of you guys
i'ma just go right past
all of you
all right so
it's got got to do do they fight back
they do but i i gotta let them fight
back
i don't want to see how much damage that
does
oh damn
scared me
let's go down here and get these archers
oh
i think that's all i think there might
be some in the back i know there's some
right here
on your run down
can i get him
let's get let's go let's go let's go
oh there's a there's an archer here hey
what you doing here buddy
oh my god man i pushed the wrong button
i pushed the wrong button
ah i switched weapons
i feel ashamed of myself man i feel
shame
i had that that was mine i don't know
what would happen when i did something
to his legs but
something was mine i just don't know
just don't know man
here we go again across the the burning
bridge
i'm tired of crossing this bridge
i know i'm better than this
not picking none of that up they trying
to kill me
[Applause]
not picking none of that up
gotcha
that's i think that was the third
attempt for this boss
i mean if you want to count the first
attempt which you can if you want
because i literally the the boss started
i got hit by him almost immediately
so
uh
uh
oh i don't got long to kill this dude
[Music]
yeah i'm not doing that
i don't even know why he showed his mug
up there
i didn't ask for his opinion
oh my god
is he dead he is
what did he drop it's very important i
know what he draws
nothing worthwhile let's move on
oh no no no no
[Music]
he ended up living didn't
ah i gotta worry about him now when i go
down there let's let these
these things come down a little bit
they still live i don't understand how
they live from such a fall
[Music]
i think it's full
let's see how many arguments
i see one there there's two
at least they're on one side so i could
take them out first
all right so there's one down here on
this for autumn one
me
oh my god these stupid things like my
thing is
you hit him one time and they go over
i play like half the game with half your
health
running out of
yo i ain't gonna even complain i'm just
gonna keep playing i ain't going to
complain
now i gotta kill these blue knights
because i need some more health items
i don't want to use these yellow ones
because these give me the most help
kind of hard to say so will me i was
already dead
i was already dead will me it was
already too late
it was too late for me
[Applause]
oh my god
[Applause]
[Applause]
i personally feel like going this way is
easier than going downstairs
i don't want nothing to do with those
dogs unless the dragon does
i don't want nothing to do with those
dogs
wow
so what have they got oh here we go yum
yum yum yum yum i need all that
already look man i like the challenge i
like i just gotta
i get what i gotta do is i think i gotta
fight the
it's gotta fight them better man i gotta
fight the more strategic
oh my god
i wasn't feeling that i felt like that
was a little too much i felt like that
was a little too much
ah i feel like i got a dual hand then
people
do will
okay all right
that makes sense
i feel like it's blurry for some reason
oh i guess nothing i could do but
[Applause]
at least i got some more health
is this dragon never gonna show up
where is this dragon
[Applause]
ah
oh they're all still
um
oh here he comes he's about to blow
stuff up again
all right come on you stupid
[Music]
backstab
i assume these are my souls yup
i don't need i don't need any help i can
beat this boss without help
come on
there you go
taking forever
what do you mean i run almost
immediately out outbreak
you have to explain what you mean by
that
i'm gonna need i'm gonna need some
some explanations are you are you saying
that i'm being too reckless
is that what you saying explain
what raven meant
what's up buddy
all right so i guess the best way to do
is to wait for the attack oh i can't get
behind them
that that that's that's that's swell
[Music]
oh my god
all right so the right trigger with this
i don't even know how that move hit me
oh oh you almost had me you big buffy
night
you almost had me
almost had
failed though he failed to deliver the
final blow
oh
that hit me
i don't feel like that should have hit
me
oh so this should be
there should be one over here
all right where is this night
knights over there
oh god
all right here we go yeah i was about to
say a customer man
i i promised i promised i wouldn't cuss
in here so
let's get close
oh my god
oh my god
i just don't like being so slow man
i can't stand it
i'm gonna try to fight him faster
because i can't stand being that slow
it's not even possible to be that slow
why am i still slow
i was told to wear all the armor go
figure
i'm still
well i i didn't just i didn't just farm
over and over again by the way
you know i i didn't just sit here for an
hour
two hours and just do nothing
stop doing that move
there's another area i could go to
was unaware of that
i ain't even trying to deal with these
people like loki
i ain't even trying to deal with these
people
i should have probably picked that up
just on the rail
oh my god
oh i
would be so bad at these archers
wouldn't fall the way they do
because it makes it makes it so much
harder to kill him when i have to kill
an archer down
one hit he fell
no that he pushed him off oh my god
that should be all except for the dumb
ones that have left down
oh
hey
oh damn i didn't mean to do that
hmm
oh i feel like i did better that time i
was more agile
i need to to go to another area
because i need better armor man like i
can't just keep fighting this dude with
with this wack armor i have
because because they're they're
one-shotting me
i assume this is how you go to other
places in the game okay
i have no clue where i am
this sounds like some kind of
what is that oh no it's one of those
things it's not getting away this time
no
i don't even know what that was
i don't even need a pool like a farm i
just need better armor because
the thing is is like i'm naked
like i don't like look at this look at
this
wack roll
like it's not even possible to roll this
slow in real life
i like to use this spear like on the
reel
i'd like to use this spear i felt like
the sphere would be nice
i'm a very
you farm to carry more weight i don't
want to farm though man that seems so
black
and it doesn't look like i can't even do
anything here
i need more something oh god
oh god someone throwing rocks
it's not very housewarming
let's go up here and find out this dude
throwing rocks
what is this
oh god look how much damage i'm doing
yo this is this is ridiculous
i don't think i'm supposed to be
only gave me three
this is it this isn't the way man
this isn't the way
oh this dude got an axe
what level are you i'm level seven
level seven
look i don't know where to go
oh there's a [ __ ] ton one
yeah i'm pretty sure i'm under level
they don't do as much damage i thought
they would
oh god there's a lot of them
dude's got a raw
let's get this one right here
you guys aren't that bright are you
this dude with the rock though he knows
what's up
oh
i have no clue what those do
the guys with the big drops draws lots
of crafting
so that's what that is crafting oh it's
the dogs yeah
i'm not dealing with dogs dogs is where
i draw the line
not dealing with dogs
i draw the line that oh i guess it
doesn't matter i'm dead
i'm dead anyway doesn't matter
oh my god i guess i will
grind just a little bit well i guess i
want to grind i got all these souls
i mean that gave me a thousand
all right so now let's go down here
what should i level up what kind of
character should i make
if you have damage or a dagger for them
more damage check if you have a spear
or a dagger for them more damage i do
have a spear and i believe i have a
dagger as well
um i kind of want to use the spear
part of me wants to use the spear so
that means i have to go up in strength
correct
that's how that works yeah strength
like is it going to be that much of a
difference though
like or should i go in vitality for more
health
i mean that's 477 health erica
that's nothing to to joke at
or should i have it should i do that
should i do that is that what i should
do is that the move we should make
i feel like two and two is good man feel
like two and two
if anything maybe one in three
one and three two and two what should it
be
what should i just put them all on
string say yolo i don't need help
art thou finished may thy strength
help the world be mended
oh this gives me 800 a pop let's go
but hopefully you know okay hold daniel
i got i this is this is my mindset okay
if i invest it into strength i will be
stronger so i can roll
an armor now i don't know if i can roll
the armor i the royal eye type of role i
want to do
but i do feel like i can row to a point
where i i don't look like a sludge
trying to do a backflip man
so i can level up a couple more times
physical strength be granted so the
world might be mended
equip burden
all right so i gotta level up endurance
to make it to where i can do something
no hold up hold up erica erica
just hear me out haircut hear me out
wouldn't it be easier for me to level up
an endurance
so i can actually wear something
and look look it gets my standard up as
well erica i feel like that's
a good good justification to go on
endurance
because i mean i level that up
i i'll level up in uh it's strength
because i can definitely
use the more power
may thy strength help
now see you see at these these swords do
better damage man i expect them
to scare people now and i want to get
better
all right so i'm gonna i'm gonna skip
these people like i skipped the last one
because i don't need to fight them
i just think the slugs don't give me
enough
enough justification to fight them if
you guys get what i'm saying
can you guys hear me fine though because
i had to like
make my mic go down a little bit i just
want to make sure you guys hear me fine
ah that was not necessary dragon
the that was not
[Applause]
where did you come from
yeah you you can uh you can give me
what you guys opinion on what i should
do uh but keep in mind if
if i think it's dumb i'll i'll i'll i'll
call you out on it man
no no no giving whatsoever man i'll call
y'all i'll say how dumb
well this this this thing doesn't do
damage at all
it doesn't do any damage
that upsets me too because i really
really wanted
to use more of a uh
i wanted to use more what's all i'm
looking for
wanted to do more in terms of like like
a little long range thing
because i love spears and dark souls one
i used a lot of spears
i hate this place because i can't see
anything
but i hear
look at this
look at them trying to sneak stuff on me
man
trying to sneak the the nonsense
get the clever right ring and
it's game over what's the mortar and
blade i probably messed that up man
you have to apologize i have no clue
what that is
stop bleeding counter poison
okay so i could resurrect my body if i
wanted to but i don't think
it's a good thing to resurrect my body
this these stupid dogs are about to kill
me again i have a huge feeling
what you doing
so there's one there's one puppy gone
the next one
there's another puppy gone
magic that's what people keep telling me
but i ain't trying to beat it that way
man
i feel a certain way oh there's a bunch
of puppies
i'm at the attack eventually
i hate that little pump move why does it
do this i don't want to pop you i want
to hit you
that pump move is getting on my nerves
and it doesn't do it any other time if
you're
that pump move is so
stupid
oh my gosh
it's my issue with this game man
that's that's one of the reasons that
like i got it
like i feel like some of some of the oh
i was too close to him isn't that
something
i don't think i'm gonna make it in time
too
[Applause]
a fire long sword i think are you
counting the the thing that i can make a
fire long sword
yeah the dragon definitely hit me man
the dragon definitely hit me
it was complete accident i didn't mean
for him to hit me like that
there's my souls let me go grab those
wasn't a lot of souls but they were mine
i deserve them
oh god oh god
reading the chat man got me messed up
reading the chat got me messed up
be prepared for the dog to kill me again
one two three
one two three
how many more is left there's two of
them
oh god oh god
oh look at the health i have that that's
that's crazy
i don't know i don't think she streamed
it
what's the boss
thanks for that
i don't keep track of what other people
stream and stuff i try to catch up on
people's streams man but
i just work so much it's hard people be
streaming like every day don't know
where i'm at
[Applause]
uh what's up here oh it's these people
there we go
hopefully those
oh
bam
god that's what i needed i need these
half moon grass
i feel like they're very helpful
or i could just die like i just did
there it's kind of hard to dodge that
move because i feel like it's got such a
wide range if you don't have armor on
it's gonna kill you
but i'm awake my i'm gonna make my way
back over there again and get
get all those souls
i'm gonna try to fight man i'm gonna try
should i go back downstairs well i can't
go downstairs yet
i gotta wait
do you ever fight these dragons because
i hope so
because they make my life a living hell
i want to fight these dragons
dragons get on my nerves
what's up hiding like you are
you can't kill so do you like do you
come back here to kill them is that how
it works
i like to get one at a time two is too
small
come on man what's up neo's part
team addict let's go
the red one the red one's the one that's
causing all the issues man
it better be that red one that's the
only one that matters
i don't want to fight the w what one of
them was blue wasn't it
i wanna fight the blue one the blue one
ain't really done nothing to me
all right
thanks for that it's this red one that's
that
that'd be causing it yeah
how am i liking the game i like it it's
okay
you know i do think that people try to
to make this game like
like really
the blue one ain't done nothing to me
why would i attack the blue one
it's that dude there
it's doing some nonsense
it always be the red one doing the most
i really hate that move like on the reel
i hate that move
bolts i have no clue what i use both
what's that sound
oh you better reload
if the game it's the game they started
at all
it wasn't kingsville
i still i i like it though it is an
enjoyable experience
well i've been wanting to get that for a
minute i got it
you guys see what i mean by that stupid
move
like come on he did it twice
i don't understand why he does that
i get so upset it's not that i hit a
wall man
it's just i don't like this stupid
mechanic to where when you're right in
front of someone
instead of killing them you try to push
them
because it just makes the fighting so
inconsistent
instead of actually hitting with my
sword he pushes him
why i didn't ask to push anyone
like that that archer was dead but
instead of dying
i push him i don't understand the
mentality on that [ __ ]
[Applause]
ah
uh
they're not even that bad what makes it
bad is the fact that when i do try
like it's the archers because i can't
really fight the archers in him
at the same time very effectively and i
should not have picked that up because
it's probably gonna get me killed
see look at that again
i'm about to i'm lowkey about to drop
this game because of that stupid push
move like
i'm low-key about to drop the game
because when i go to attack
someone he pushes him
what scenario would you want to push
someone
what scenario
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god
of course bolts i don't need bolts there
we go give me some healing abilities
you can't attract them the knights that
the archers don't do that
the archers will run back they won't
they won't just come
at you like that and where am i going to
attract them from
there's a dragon breathing fire
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die
oh great i didn't even have my shield
out
[Applause]
oh great
you know what i'ma just fight this dude
with the stupid
archers i'd rather dodge the archers
than dodge him
like and the part that blows my mind
is if i go kill those archers the other
blue dude shows up
you know what i'm done playing with this
dude
can i even use this
so i got bolts but i guess they need a
crossbow
ain't that soon ain't that
i need a crossbow i don't have a cross
they keep giving me bolts to equipment i
don't have
i can't really parry a a bow
like the the night himself is not the
issue
i can destroy that night
the night is not the issue oh my god
[Applause]
i'm gonna try i'm gonna try using a bow
man i don't know if it'll work well
i'ma try using a bow
no i can't i really can i know i know it
looks like i'm capping
but i i can i can destroy the night like
the night's not an issue
it's the bow the night is not ish
look at that there was no reason did you
see that
he was literally not even close to him
and he went to
put his sword
i'm losing my patience with this game
like on the real i am losing my patience
with this game
watch this arrow take like no health at
all
oh
what the hell
at least i grabbed the souls that would
have been
very unfortunate if i didn't grab those
souls
i'ma just do the only effective thing
i've done is is two hand
one two of the archers
it's not even the backstabbing man like
i want to backstab him
i need to set up my third monitor it
makes a lot harder
because on one of my monitors is the
playstation this monitor is the stream
with the chat
and i want the third monitor to show the
uh
i want the third monitor to to show the
actual live stream
i'm not gonna drop the game i'm just
frustrated
what is an arc stone i don't know what
you mean man you got to be a little more
specific
i don't know this game like that
wait can i use that bow from here
i ain't gonna stay here do that all damn
day
ah
[Music]
give me this ow
look at this dude hiding within
oh
are we just going to keep doing this
over and over again
like i said the knights are not an issue
it's the stupid archers that are an
issue
[Music]
uh
probably could have made that
so
come on do your little breathing fire
[ __ ]
oh i don't know if i'm gonna make it
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
oh i thought he had me though for a
second
[Applause]
that is perfectly fine let's pop let's
pop
a little bit of health though let's not
get killed by these stupid globs
they be throwing stuff man get on my
nerves
dude is this the casual speed run go
explore the other worlds
i went to other worlds man and i felt
like i didn't like i wasn't really
getting anything done there
man she keeps moving i don't like that
she needs to stay put
then touch the the demons
key to life's ether soul of the lost
withdrawn from its vessel
let's transfigure arthur all right let's
try to fight this dude again let's try
fighting
let's try fighting this dude again
okay let's do this
ow
saw an item right here
that was worth it
and i just never played this game and
it's
it's it's a little like this game's a
little bit different than like
bloodborne in them
like because i'm not used to having to
like rely so much on shields and stuff
that's why i'm used to like rolling
added scenarios i'm not used to doing
this
it's always different places
oh no no you're perfectly fine man i i
said backseat game is fine
if i start losing my stuff too much i'll
go to the fourth one how about that
[Applause]
this dragon likes taking his time
oh
[Music]
true
see i like he gives me those those are
really helpful
him
[Music]
archers
uh
[Music]
oh
uh
[Music]
how did i get hit by that
i find that kind of ridiculous
uh
i knew that was a bad idea
get up
are you serious are you serious
are you serious oh wow
wow wow i tripped him
and i went to run to recover and i
didn't know it
wow
hmm
my
[Music]
hmm
is he changing up no he's not okay
[Music]
next time he slams that [ __ ] i'm going
for it
[ __ ] it i'm going for it now oh man i
didn't mean to cut my back cog needle
get up
let's do two to three every hit no need
to do any more than two to three
let's not get greedy we ain't we ain't
messing this up because of greediness
man
get by
get over there
oh
oh good date i can forge weapons for you
was it my first try daniel
it was like my fourth or fifth i don't
know
did you come back alive
now i knew how to fight him
just from fighting the last time i
didn't know he fell like that that's why
i like
because when i heard the noise when he
fell the first time
i thought he was jumping up or something
so i just took off i wasn't even trying
to mess with that
let's trans be granted so the world
might be mended
so the world might be mended
strength
look man it was it was rough i ain't
going to sit here and try to say
like him himself wasn't rough after i
figured out when i go to
duel him and i push the right bumper
twice i realized that it was killing
those
those knights of one hit those archers
so it wasn't really an issue
all right so i can't go any further
unless i kill an arch demon
all right homeboy said to go to world
four so i'm gonna go to world four
no i'm definitely not going for the play
the platinums don't mean nothing to me
i have a feeling about to go to war four
and get and get destroyed
one two three
i assume this is for
i wouldn't want other stone
i'm already not feeling this man
at least he gave me a lot of souls
hmm
hmm
are they like shooting magical arrows at
me or something
what an idiot
uh
so far that their movements are pretty
pretty readable
a homeboy shooting some crazy
so
all right so the plexus team is so of
the
i assume you can make them into weapons
perhaps
because sometimes with these games you
can turn like bosses and weapons
withdrawn from its vessels
[Music]
wonder what luck does item discovery and
some resistance
maybe like the luck of you getting
poisoned et cetera et cetera
that's what i would assume
so
uh
give you a good amount of xp though
[Music]
die on purpose in the nexus
i feel like you guys are trolling me
feel the control of me man
i feel like blocking those magical
arrows won't do anything
oh i'm about to find out what eric was
talking about
fighting two of them
oh my god you right let's not fight two
of them together
and i'm bleeding apparently i don't know
what that means
uh
yeah i died i know i know
what is great world like i feel like i'm
so left out
oh
chief
damn they they can catch up with me
they always be doing this weird stuff
man
so fighting the bosses and stuff while
undead is harder
do you just like do more damage in your
life or something
so
foreign
he's like shooting two at a time
uh
if you see a red sketchy skelly you'll
know
so what does that mean
guy's confusing me man i don't know what
you're talking about
oh he's gonna catch me
there we go
but in black the enemies are tougher
they they're black phantoms once
that are like mini bosses oh my god
all this unnecessary stuff man
so if i keep dying in this like
in the undead round that's what happens
oh my god
yeah i'm fine now
so when am i not fine
that's my question what am i not fine
someone explained the not fine mentality
to me because i don't know
so the more you die with your full
health the worse it gets
oh if i die in the nexus
it makes things easier in the world
world
i think that's what you guys are saying
uh
ow
can destiny get this
i i i haven't played destiny in a little
bit i need to jump back on it
so you guys happy that uh sony changed
their mind about the playstation thing
because i personally didn't care but i
know a lot of people to do
uh
it's kind of dumb i'm gonna be honest
but that's demon so
it is demon souls what's
what's a good weapon
get that health back
let's finish it got him
i feel like 5000 is enough to go to the
nexus
i don't know what i'm doing man i i have
no clue what i'm doing yet
the the sword i have now looks like it's
trash man what you talking about
use the swords you have
guys out your mind
well today is monday in this that means
tomorrow is the day any weapon is good
if you build right
let me ask you guys a question i assume
if i use this
it's going to give me a bunch of souls
in return for his soul himself correct
is that how it works
where did this chick go now uh she's
over here
now then touch the soul of the mind
key to life's ether soul of the lost
withdrawn from its vessel
are thou finished save the souls
all right so is there a reason why i
want to save the souls
people need to inform me man because if
it's some wack weapon that i'm never
going to use
i have no problem getting rid of that
i'm getting faster a little bit faster
i can forge weapons for you
all right so he's got like a little bit
of everything here
a heater shell a short sword
it's got a little everything man a
little everything who sells armor
when do you sell armor do you sell on
i'm stopping my wife but i would be
worthless and i would be happy to
lighten your load
and look after any excess baggage
you're useless fam i want someone to
sell me armor
you've gone and died have you
if you die here what are you doing
even i will not just
sit back and take it
sit back down fan
you've gone and die have you if you die
here
your soul will return to this temple
well what will you do next
give up that's what i did
i think i just lost my nerve for this
kind of thing
good give me that armor they don't look
heavy
give me the armor then no need for you
to have if you're gonna be
gonna gonna be a pansy just stay in here
you can you can give me that armor
ain't nobody gonna question you
hey where is this shirt
i can forge weapons for you
all right so is it is it worth spinning
souls to upgrade this
hit him addict look i don't trust you
guys
like erica was right last time you guys
are setting me up to fail
i feel like i hit him it's going to do
some crazy stuff and i ain't trying to
do that
so interesting
what's the stats required to use this
they don't really tell you a whole lot
do they
oh that's a dagger
all right let's do this
i've been here before
what is this dude hello there
a pickaxe a bunch of stuff i don't think
i need
i hear
a smith in the background
but i can't get to him i think i gotta
go around to get to him
oh yeah it's the rock throne people man
oh
oh i feel bad for them
not really
[Music]
come on man
come on
[Music]
oh gosh oh it's the dogs
the dogs man
oh gosh
gotcha
they're kind of slow a little bit
just a little bit slow
[Music]
[ __ ]
all right
yo that dude was about to do something
slightly stuff to me
wow
throwing some fireballs don't scare me
waves at me
well you gotta go and call tonight man i
don't know how long i streamed it was
it was uh almost three hours i
appreciate everyone coming by i'm going
to stream this next week
uh beat this art stone wherever we are
i'm pretty sure it saves automatically
appreciate everyone coming by